Good day, actor Mejía greets you with his
brief informative for today, Thursday,
August 19. An important federal decision
in the state of Nevada on an
immigration law could have repercussions at
the national level. Judge Miranda Du
declared unconstitutional the federal law
that she considers as a  crime the
re-entry of deported immigrants
magistrate adu added that the creation of
the federal law in 1929 was
motivated by prejudices against
Mexicans and other Latinos, she also said
that the origin of the mandate
disproportionately impacts the
Latino population the case that prompted the
decision  It began with the arrest of a
man who, despite having been
originally deported in 1999,
was arrested again 20 years later
here in the country. The judicial department
has not indicated whether it will appeal the
decision.
The crisis in Afghanistan has the
community concerned about some
local organizations are
preparing to receive and help the
refugees  two who can leave the country
among them are Catholic charities that
reported that at least 500 Afghans could
arrive in the city in the next year the
non-profit organization provides
refugees with food, clothing and
shelter as long as they can support
themselves in the meantime  the
veterans association is also assisting
families and members of the us
military impacted
by the war in afghanistan and has
coordinated several counseling sessions
around the valley
the clark county school district
which is reporting 350 positive cases
of kobe since  that classes started
last week some
cis teachers and stee say that there are colleagues who
are not following the
safety protocols an educator said that the
return of all students
complicates to be able to comply with the
social distancing regulation claim especially small classrooms
teachers are asking parents to
for the safety of the campuses
make sure your children practice good
hygiene and have their
masks on
tonight there is another vex giveaway
deny james anyone who gets at least
one dose of the
vaccine enters this giveaway you can win anything
from cash to a pass
state parks the million dollar grand prize
is august 26th now take a
look at the weather forecast
we will have temperatures in the 90's
by today thursday in the
70's by tonight and no rain in our
forecast have a nice day  I am
Héctor Mejía and this was your brief
Spanish x-men news
[Music]